i don't think you can
compare in in any way
uh the the difference of what's going on
here this is um you know one occasion
that that care has answered fully which
is that he was in a constituency office
uh with a con labor colleague uh
campaigning uh in a by-election they
were busy making calls having done a
visit they broke from uh making calls to
stand in the kitchen for 20 minutes to
eat some sandwiches and and have a drink
before resuming um uh making uh those uh
phone calls and uh that's you know
is very much you know what you might
describe uh as a work event i think what
we are seeing what we have seen in
downing streets uh revelation after
revelation
is uh
social gatherings on an industrial scale
pre-organized with invitations going out
with alcohol being ordered especially
trestle tables being put up and the like
uh with um with people seemingly raising
concerns about whether that was
appropriate or not right through that
initial lockdown and
uh beyond uh with then the prime
minister and the government uh lying
about it denying it took place unable to
answer basic questions over many many
weeks now that this has been uh
happening and that's why the prime
minister has lost authority and he's
lost trust and people just perceive him
uh as as being a liar about these things
i think had he said uh at the beginning
of all of this look
there was this one event that i went to
i i saw it was a work event we were i
was working we were all working we all
went back to work straight afterwards
you know and put his hands up about that
full disclosure i think people would
have been
forgiving completely forgiving of that
but that's not what we've seen here
the difference seems to be between the
event that your leader went to on the
30th of april uh 2021 and the one of the
prime minister on the 20th of may 2020
both work events were being told um one
of them was cheese and wine and crisps
the other one was beer and sandwiches uh
one lasted 20 minutes the other lasted
25 minutes
no i think um you know what we've uh
seen and as as you say this is just one
of i think 17 um parties that we now
know about
the prime minister attended we're
talking about the leader
the prime minister
well we don't know we don't know all of
that but this was a a pre-arranged
invitation it was after work it was not
drawing work inviting didn't know that
tells us he didn't know that 100 people
well he does now and he should have
known it he should have known him
when he stood up when he stood up in
parliament months ago and said that no
rules have been broken no party no party
took place is what he said he said he
hadn't attended parties i would have if
i had been him uh and i'm sure the same
with of kierstama i would have thought
to myself oh hang on a minute wasn't
there that thing that i went to
uh when we were in the middle of
lockdown in in in april 2020 where a lot
of people were there and when we're
drinking wine shouldn't i say something
about that now now that i'm being asked
about parties
it was at the end of a long day he went
out to get some fresh air it was the end
of a long day he went out to get some
fresh air
to get some fresh that's what he
and how can we prove otherwise your
leader broke off went into the kitchen
had a body and a beer and went back um
my viewers this morning will be thinking
they're all as bad as one another
well that's what you see that's exactly
what the government want you to think
that's exactly what they want to think
because they want to distract from their
own very serious situation now the prime
minister by his own admission regrets
that that happening and he said that he
wished that he'd sent everybody back
inside i he i.e he understood it to have
been a social gathering a social
gathering in in the in the workplace uh
which is not the same as getting
something to eat in in the in the
workplace they want to tar everybody
with the same brush because they want
that then to become a problem for
everybody instead of what it actually is
which is industrial scale partying and
industrial scale cover up and lying
about all of those
gatherings many of which were completely
pre-arranged invitations went out wine
fridges were stocked up trestle tables
were were put out djs were arranged you
know this is industrial scale partying
but then the prime minister has denied
and lied about in parliament and
elsewhere for many many weeks to cover
up which is why he is now unable to
address the really big issues facing
this country that people want him to be
addressing like the cost of living
prices like the fact that all our energy
bills are going to go up by tens of
pounds a month uh in the next few weeks
food prices are going up transport costs
are going up petrol costs are going up
rents are at their highest level ever
and he's just put taxes up on on
ordinary working people that's coming in
in a couple of months as well they want
a prime minister that can address these
issues not who's hiding away in downing
street thinking up controversial
policies that can distract the public
from uh the attention of what he's
actually done and what he should be
accountable for nor trying to rape up
something because he's been addressed by
kierst dahmer on many okay
and isn't that the point isn't that what
the opposition should be doing right now
rather than worrying about parties or
otherwise that happened um up to two
years ago what you should be doing is
holding the government's feet to the
fire when it comes to the cost of living
the fact that more than 25 percent of
homes more than a quarter of all homes
will be in feel poverty uh by april of
this year and we are potentially sending
military vessels to uh take on sinking
dinghies in the channel isn't that what
the opposition should be focusing on
well that's exactly what we have been
focusing on we've come up with a big
bold plan to address the cost of energy
in in this country
a cut to v80 that would mean uh 200
pounds off the average every every
average household uh in this uh country
as well as a windfall tax on the uh
north sea oil and gas and others who
made a right boon out of uh out of this
energy crisis that that could increase
uh the
the discount for those on the lowest pay
for around about 600 pounds a year this
is a big bold policy that we've come up
with because we're not distracted by our
own uh leadership uh crisis and we're
not distracted by our leader having no
authority and no uh respect and we're
able to come up with these big ideas and
that's what
that's what we need from the government
right now and they're just not doing
that